екс-президенту Віктору Януковичу
закидають державну зраду пособництва в
умисних діях вчинених з метою зміни меж
території та державного кордону України
а також пособництво у введенні
агресивної війни
покарання де ж зрада в Україні карається
позбавленням волі на строк від 12 до 15
років запособництво уведення агресивної
війни від 10 до 15 років за посягання На
територіальну цілісність держави
максимальний термін покарання від 10 до
15 років або довічне позбавлення волі за
усіма статтями можлива конфіскація
майна доказова база ключовими доказами є
листи Віктора Януковича російському
президентові Володимиру Путіну та раді
Федерації Росії з проханням ввести
війська в Україну серед інших доказів
заяви свідків документи висновки
експертів речові відео та
фотодокази свідків в справі Загалом у
справі опитали понад 100 свідків одним з
них був і ексдепутат Державної Думи
Російської Федерації Денис вороненков
якого наприкінці березня застрелив
Кіллер у центрі Києва позиція адвокатів
захист Януковича вважає що передача до
суду справи про державну зраду
екс-президента незаконна за словами
адвоката Віталія сердюка для розгляду
справи Немає правових підстав оскільки
Януковичу досі не вручили повідомлення
про підозру інші кримінальні справи
Януковича Віктор Янукович фігурує ще у
кількох кримінальних провадженнях серед
них справа Майдану в якій розслідують
хто саме наказав застосувати надмірні
силові заходи спецзасоби та вогнепальну
зброю до учасників масових акцій
протесту з листопада 2013 року по лютий
2014 року також екс-президент є
підозрюваним у справі межигир'я та
незаконному заволодінні коштів
держбюджету у справі
Укртелекому